let's get it now we're again whoa
whoa
whoa did you guys see that that dude
oh [ __ ]
what did rocket league do on this update
man i have no idea
oh my god
that wasn't right
oh we're against danny too
okay we know danny's super aggressive
og not so much
we know that from the last game can't
believe i missed that boost that's
really bad
should i be going for that absolutely
not that was so bad
we're going to get boost though
danny's going to hit it to the wall
kai's going to run him down
kind of wish he didn't touch that
because that was bad
pretty sure our teammate was dead
so we're good
[Music]
i'm just gonna play back again i might
want to pick up the aggression slightly
i'm playing a lot of defense because my
teammates
are refusing to rotate of course
you know very typical ranked experience
it is what it is
glad i didn't go for that though play
left side
could have gone for that man
oh
how did i get any height on that there
we go
i don't know what the heck shinx doing
go for some controlled touches here down
to kyo
should have been a goal
should have been a goal should have been
a goal
we didn't get it though that's okay
get another opportunity here kyle missed
[Music]
do you
oh thank you frosty i appreciate that
man
good to have you here
not my best touch we're just gonna hit
it around there it was much better
pog giving us the ball
needed a little bit of help that's okay
nice
it's tough to trust shake there
just playing back again because there's
no rotation going on currently
so we're just letting the team
hit the ball around and play ping pong
and we're gonna wait for our opportunity
basically that's all we're doing
like right there that's a good
opportunity it was a good shot didn't go
in but
it's better than me aping around hitting
the ball poorly like the rest of this
lobby
to me
it's a really bad touch actually i'm
gonna hit it down to my boy
that pass was way too slow
i'm gonna slow it down
avoid a demo
that was the right idea i just didn't
execute on the shot
i want to hit that a lot higher
nice teethed it up for our boy
and go for this left boost
shanks good
try to hit it around that guy
probably should have just gone for a
better 50
but it'll work
it was a really odd save
i don't know what shinx doing again
shank is struggling we need to try and
get shinks's confidence up here
get him some really good passes or
something
but his uh rotations are
literally non-existent right now
yep
that's fine they double committed into
an opponent's corner that's always good
hey maybe i'm ruining shanks confidence
with all these passes man
i'm literally teeing the ball up for
this guy and he's just
being let down unfortunately
that's a good pass
i think should be there
come on shake
okay
okay
i don't know how i'm still going for
this ball
but that's a good 50.
yeah we're trying to do our best here
i think
oh almost scored
perfect pass
that was almost really scary based on
where shank was
the shank's still in the corner and he
turned here
so if i mess this up or get a bad 50
that's going to be really bad for us
but
we scored instead which is huge
huge man
okay
we want the boost we got the boost room
i'm gonna pop it in the air that was
kind of delayed touch
good shot shank
i think that's a dub
that's dub baby
think
hopefully i shouldn't say that
i've lost games like this before there
we go
gg
it wasn't easy because our teammates
didn't rotate very much made the game
harder than it needed to be but that's
how that's literally how ranked works
nowadays
you just gotta deal with it man
you just gotta deal with it everyone's
out doing their own thing you just gotta
be able to morph into it i hate this map
bro
it's way too [ __ ] dark on this map
man
[Music]
oh
yikers dude
that's a banger
all right we're playing third man like
we usually do
[Music]
somebody should definitely be there for
that but that's okay
we're gonna hit the ball up for one of
our boys or not
[Music]
why are we going for an air dribble here
i'll never know
i just balled my teammate not cool
might be
that was a good play
can you freestyle well i'm playing
ranked so i don't want to freestyle
[Music]
you know
i want to have really good touches and
shots and passes and saves
that's the second time i've done that
hopefully he's okay he is
both of these guys are going for the
corner boost in our end
that's really weird
very very strange they're doing it again
actually the heck is going on
just gonna boom it that was a bad boom
this guy's going for our corner again
it's not oh my god okay so we're playing
uh we're playing a weird mimi team here
okay
they're playing specifically to [ __ ] me
up
that's okay i'm gonna play more
aggressive to literally combat that i'm
gonna play a bit faster
oh almost got the second touch
i'm gonna definitely speed it up here
okay
sorry ethan
i see that you have it now
pass to ethan
pass up to me again i guess i don't know
i think that was a good 50.
this is annoying okay
and play here
definitely not the touch bongo is
looking for
let's go back
i'm just going to wait
take control
click
um that should lead to a good
opportunity if bungo can hit that
not the best touch actually
really good touch by that guy though
ethan really loves to just dominate my
body huh
it's not in the way that i like though
what
okay
i don't know what that was but we'll
take it
i think ethan's in trouble try and help
him out we got the save sick
good job bungo
so ethan's playing really bad uh we're
gonna try and help him out as best we
can
he keeps bumping into me because he
doesn't you know
what's new he doesn't rotate it's very
typical it's all right
we're gonna deal with it bring up his
confidence let him play the way that he
wants to
get his confidence up just like that
make it easy for him
totally fine
he likes to kiss my car i'm not sure why
but
hey it is what it is
can you be my dad
um
no i'm sorry
good job ethan
uh okay bunga's good i'm gonna display
net here
this is pretty bad because i didn't get
a boost off this kickoff
just gonna wait here there's really
nothing else for me to do anyway so
wait midfield that's a pass to ethan
really bad touch
we're gonna play it fast though
go control flick
wait for them to [ __ ] up maybe go for a
demo on someone
oh they had a really good outlet
nice
passive mid
oh we actually got the clear
should be okay yep good job ethan
ethan's got his confidence back he's
pogging out
that's what we like to see
i don't know where the boost is
or when it was taken
bongo did not need to go that far
outfield
but we're living with it
that's how we do
they just didn't go for the ball faked
my ass out i'm trash
probably the best 50 you guys have ever
seen
that was so awkward the heck
okay we're up one ten seconds left we
don't need to do anything crazy we got
the boost
uh we're gonna get in front of bongo
great touch
two one
play back here
easy win
boom
gg good game so basically all i'm doing
is like first minute of the game i'm
analyzing the match
trying to see what my teammates are
capable of i noticed that ethan was
not rotating
hitting teammates going for bad balls
bad touches so it's like okay
you have to you have to play around that
as best you can without like just
completely ignoring his existence you
can make bad players play better
that's kind of how you
get
i don't know i guess that's called being
a leader i guess
he's like i'm doing the things that make
him more comfortable so that he can play
better when he's not playing well does
that make sense
i think that makes sense i've been
trying to do that ranked and it's been
working